currently in clear second place wesley
saw you had a marathon game we're not
going to keep you here too long just
yeah
[Laughter]
tell us some things you want to say
about the game no of course i'm very
pleased to to win because
if you push for what five five and a
half hours
the last thing you want is uh is a draw
after pushing so so hard and
using a lot of energy so i'm very
pleased uh
fabiano is obviously a great player and
he's one of the
he's probably the best prepared player
in the petrov
so i went for this quiet line
which
worked surprisingly enough uh so on move
15 g5 was interesting
it seems like you were very well aware
of the position up to here you played
very quickly but g5 kind of struck you
yeah i actually prepared this line the
olympiad so i was thinking to play the
better off and one of my opponents plays
this line with white
and i also played it in uh rap or online
rapid against cnn bomniachi that also
worked quite well so
yeah normally
so fabian has been playing correctly all
the way here
g5 is quite ambitious obviously black
has many moves
so knight f3 knight f5 he had weakened
his position a little bit but also his
knights were active and i wasn't sure
what to play with knight on e4
but in the middle game he he sacrificed
upon yeah after bishop e6 right well
partly taking was a mistake
yes i sacrificed a pawn like
my relief is that
his knight took like three moves to get
to e4 because i forced him to retreat
like normally in the petrol if we get
the knight on e4 right away right and
then
i took a point i thought i must be
better
but were you surprised i didn't take it
back
oh i thought i have knights before after
it takes right but i wasn't sure ah so
it's just slightly better it's still a
pawn right yeah i disappointed black
equalizers and queens no no he's
far from equalizing oh okay but the
other one you're just a problem at the
position
yeah so fabiano is a great player and he
plays four win with both colors
in
a better position or worse position
so i wasn't surprised when he played
f5 i it looks playable and also we were
getting quite low on time
i probably didn't play the most accurate
moves like on all 26 i was thinking to
play c4
but i wasn't sure how good it is here's
c4 yeah i think that play c4 maybe it's
better
but in the game
i don't know he just went for an all-out
attack with h5 and wasn't sure what was
going on but i was upon up and
uh uh he was almost regaining it but
fortunately i was able to keep some
pressure uh
just a few moves before the time control
moved forward
yeah you eventually found this really
nice move a knight h for a little bit
later
yeah like the queen end game i wasn't
sure if it was winning
i mean
black has very good chances to drone and
i thought this knight h4
one second while we got here micked up
again
i think yeah i thought with the
with his past one on on these four black
is very good chances to hold yeah so
it's calculating age four and i thought
it was my last chance to win so i
decided to seize it
right but um
yeah after
yeah because the problem is bishop is
well centralized so i wasn't sure what
was happening probably he missed a draw
at some point on move 52.
52 let's see right here with the move
king
g6 here yeah the the stronger interests
think they're winning anyway so even on
move 51 even on yeah uh maybe yeah yeah
yeah after queen e2 f4 yeah you are
winning in this position according to
the stronger engines
tell us a little bit about that line
that you were calculating near the end
with him
uh here this bishop oh yeah
i thought bishop takes g4 was enough for
a draw but apparently it isn't no what
did you calculate here so
knight takes yes
d2 yes win the 8th king
g7 oh and i didn't see f5 you didn't see
f5 but we thought that if you got to
this position you might see it i'm going
to play queen d4 knight f2 but why does
f5 win so f5 f6 is made if you're
allowed queen f6 is made
yeah you can see that
why is it made come on
what okay so queen f6 king of seven
and then how do you check winner fix ah
yeah
king h7 oh i didn't see queen of six
i'll king j8986 yes yeah yeah yeah
that's the trick knight h6 on mate oh
okay difficult though yeah it's not easy
when you have two minutes on the clock
absolutely not but he didn't go for that
and you uh eventually won that quite
smoothly yeah queen and it's very
dangerous combo combination yes i like
what yasser thinks so tell us
tell us a little bit well i have to ask
hans demon oh yeah
thought the shop of the tournament well
i was watching his games in miami
they call him
the chess villain
so
basically he learned a lot from losing
all his matches in miami i mean his uh
the chess villain strikes again i mean
if i played him i played with him before
and approaches like we were teammates uh
back then he was only 24-60
but
he's improved a lot he's
very determined he's very angry at
himself and his opponents and he works
hard so
he's
yeah he's got he's got a bright future
it's nice to know that we have very
strong juniors here
in the united states and not only in
india or uzbekistan
so we have we have hans niemann it's a
good change we also have fabian and
jeffrey so yeah definitely a promising
future it was a long day wesley we're
going to let you go thank you for
joining us here and good luck the rest
of the tournament thank you man
thank you thanks to wesley wesley